a veces en la vida nos sorprenden de una
manera fuerte para decirnos que el
presente es eso un regalo de dios
todo empezó cuando mi vida quedó marcada
muy marcada
al diagnosticar mi mamá con un cáncer
eso no solamente nos afecta a toda la
familia siendo todos los que los rodean
amistades y estados de ánimo
[Música]
y eso es lo que yo quería cambiar al
momento que escribí la bella zona fiesta
porque mi mamá es el resultado de muchos
milagros y gracias a dios ella está
sentada aquí escuchando esta charla
que es dedicada para ella porque haya
sido mi fuente de inspiración
decidí escribir una canción para animar
a la gente que quizás estaba pasando lo
mismo que yo con algo familiar
y esto nos lleva a veces a deprimir los
sin embargo yo quería motivar a la gente
que me estaba escuchando
motivar a esos fans que me ven por
internet
y por eso escribirlo y es una fiesta con
un mensaje que pueda trascender
al momento de hacer esta canción me
enfoqué mucho en la actitud que tenía mi
mamá
esa actitud de estar todo hacia adelante
de emprender negocios
y el tiempo valioso
el tiempo es tan valioso que cada punto
cuenta y por
hacer
muy bien
pero no tiene
sino lo que yo sentía que todo lo que
sabes sean los que sabes
cómo
ampliar ese enfoque mira frío hacia algo
positivo en la estación
[Música]
como decidí diario
no lo sé
ah
en la vida
para disipar
[Música]
y mostrar
y disfrutando quizas cantando una
canción y me dio un montón de ideas que
luego las hice en mi vídeo real y
realmente pude conectarme con la gente
de tal manera que esa canción fue
exitosísima todo el país y no solamente
en el ecuador sino que trascendió a
otros países puede escucharla en
tailandia también tengo uno de los
gimnasios
eso a mí me da entender que la vida es
un estado de ánimo cuando eres positivo
se te abren todas las puertas suceden
cosas maravillosas suceden milagros se
activan milagros de algo que esperas y
que deseas sin embargo tú decides cuándo
lograrlo y cuándo conseguirlo para mí la
vida cambio en dos años o en un año en
donde yo estaba deseando tanto viajar en
donde yo quería conocer el amor de mi
vida yo quería irme muy lejos a explorar
a ver qué había más allá del mundo y mi
actitud de aznar feliz por la vida me
abrió muchísimas puertas me hizo conocer
un montón de gente pude viajar a
tailandia
aquí esta es una fiesta grande premios
puede viajar a tailandia vivía ya seis
meses siete meses increíbles en un hotel
de cinco estrellas con toda la comida
buffet a toda hora con todos todos los
beneficios de un hotel que puedes tener
luego fue un amigo de ecuador que se
convirtió en mi esposo y precisamente
con él hablábamos una vez que me decía
él tenía otra idea de la vida de mí yo
quería casarme y tener hijos y a mis 30
años yo ya lo tenía muy claro yo ya
sabía exactamente lo que quería y no iba
a desaprovechar oportunidades o
desgastar tiempo porque para mí el
tiempo se volvió en lo más valioso de mi
vida que yo podía compartir con mi
familia que yo podía ir a conocer un
país que yo podía ir a comer rico
entonces para mí el tiempo es oro
y yo creo de casa
yo sí quiero
y necesitar
entonces como yo
15 meses
pero dijo
[Música]
y esa actitud
de poder mostrar a 100 minutos horas
tiempo y una rutina de trabajo
sí
[Música]
en una persona adulta
de ideales
eso me lo como
entonces yo siento
que cuando vives con alegría sacas lo
mejor de ti y eso es lo que yo pude
experimentar a lo largo de estos años
vivir con alegría pudo abrirme las
puertas y pudo realmente hacerme sentir
como yo quería sentirme y no desde hace
más tiempo escuchando música triste o
simplemente reprimiendo me por cosas que
no venían la pena sino que más bien
tengo 73 hábitos que me han ayudado
muchísimo a poder mantener el estado de
ánimo al máximo aunque no crean a veces
la televisión y las noticias llegan a
deprimirnos porque dices el mundo está
tan mal el mundo se va a acabar el mundo
de esto el mundo este otro no veo
televisión
no veo
de televisión lo escucho música triste
para nada tampoco no me gusta escuchar
cuando a mi esposo canta música
tristezas me encantan pero otra música
no puedo escuchar no simplemente no no
va no va con mi personalidad y la
tercera cosa que yo les recomiendo hacer
todos los días y que crean melón es como
algo que ustedes van a sentir que es que
viene con fuerza y que te abre las
puertas hacia llegar a un nivel más allá
es ser agradecido
agradecer por lo que tienes por lo que
quizás ahora no pero lo que quieres
mirar hacia adelante hacia un futuro
soñar soñar en grande cuesta lo mismo
que soñar en pequeño soñar en dónde
quieres llegar pero a la vez no perder
tu esencia no perder la humildad no
perder tu norte
porque esa persona que eres actualmente
con tu familia y con tus amigos es la
que van a recordar siempre el ser humano
que eres no los simples diplomas que
puedas ganar
entonces
de aquí y ahora
y yo
y sonríe
y
por el vida es una pieza
bien
de la gente
hola
esta tarde estando contigo te enseño
mujer está conmigo
[Música]
para tu celular
quiero más invitación
[Aplausos]
el tiempo dirá
bien
[Música]
a la cabeza
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en las fiestas con un k
y
porque estás
fiesta
ay de mí pierde la vida sólo
[Música]
fiesta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno
en garitos tendremos que estar
descontrolar tus sentidos
[Música]
sí
bien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la vida es una fiesta mi gente esa
democracia
[Aplausos]